[الموسيقى]
يسير التعليم والطعام جنبًا إلى جنب ،
وفي مدرسة واحدة في منطقة منكوبة بالجفاف
في تنزانيا ، غيّر أحد برامج الحدائق
جيلًا من أطفال المدارس
[موسيقى]
اسمي صافي أوهانا أنا أدرس
مدرسة حضرية للماساي وأنا  شكلنا
نادي البستنة
قبل أن نبدأ في
برنامج النادي هذا ، وكان لدينا الكثير من الطلاب الذين
غابوا بسبب الجوع ،
تضم مدرسة أوبراين حوالي ثلاثمائة
وستين طالبًا معظمهم
من قبيلة الماساي
وهم في الأصل مجموعة من البدو الرحل  النظام الغذائي
يتألف تقليديا من حليب اللحوم
، الدم وزراعة الدهون ،
ولم يكن تناول الخضار جزءًا من
نمط حياتهم ، ولكن في منطقة تتميز
بمستويات الفقر المدقع وندرة الغذاء ،
كان الأطفال يعانون من سوء التغذية
وكان تعليمهم يعاني من الكثير من
المدارس التي لا تقدم أي خدمات.  طعام اسمي
بيري هوجينز وأنا مدير المدرسة
هنا في مدرسة أوبراين
حتى ينتبه الماساي في الفصل ، فأنت بحاجة
إلى معدة ممتلئة إذا كنت تفكر في ذلك
ما مدى جوعك ، كيف
يمكنك التفكير فيما من المفترض أن
تتعلمه ، لذا قامت مدرسة أوبراين بعمل
شيئين بدأوا في إنشاء حديقة وبدأوا في
تقديم وجبتين يوميًا باستخدام
الخضروات التي نماوها في البداية
عندما قمنا بطهي الخضار.  قال إن
هذه هي الخضروات ، لذا يتذوقون
المعلم ،
بعضها جيد ولكن بعد بضعة أيام
من المعلم ، من الجيد أن
ينمو الطلاب وتناول الخضار
أمرًا مهمًا في مجتمع الماساي
ولا يزال ينقصه كثيرًا
في المنزل ، لذا فإن التأكيد على هذا في المدرسة هو
المكان الوحيد
لتعلمهم ، أكل الخضروات الخاصة بك ، حديقة المدرسة
تنمو كل شيء من اللفت إلى
الكرنب والطماطم والفلفل منخفض البطاطا الحلوة من CRA
وكل يوم يكون الطلاب
مسؤولين عن زراعة
المحاصيل وحصادها ، لدينا تغييرات كبيرة جدًا
وفقًا لحديقتنا
التغييرات في الدراسة الأكاديمية قام الطلاب
بتصوير الجسم بأنه صحي
ولا تقتصر هذه التغييرات على
الفصل الدراسي الذي أخذ الطلاب
ما لديهم  تعلموا في المدرسة وأعادوها إلى
المنزل بزراعة الحدائق مع
عائلاتهم وقراهم المحلية ، وهذا
يعني أن البرنامج
يعمل
هناك بالتأكيد الكثير من القضايا
التي تبقي الطلاب بعيدًا عن المدرسة ولكن
التغذية الجيدة للطلاب هي أساس جيد جدًا
لـ  وجودهم في المدرسة
أنت
[موسيقى]